premier toc toc toc toc toc toc toc
allez tac tac tac
zombie pour l'instant c'est très bien
que c'est Daniel Moreau
donc arrête s'il te plaît refais le
refais mon cœur toc toc toc
c'est zombies
zombie qui mais non mais c'est à moi de
ça
mais c'est pas possible mais on le fait
tac tu es là c'est zombie zombie King
zombie Zumba Canadian
[Applaudissements]
c'est normal ils ont mis la chanson au
début
au lieu de le mettre sur le grand frein
il y a rien à
ils n'ont pas ils l'ont mis au début je
sais que cette coiffure tout va bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi tu restes un peu comme ça je
réfléchis c'est pas mal et là tu aimes
bien je te fais ça
[Applaudissements]
attention
deuxième toc toc toc ah c'est une de mes
chansons préférées j'adore
déjà tu vas taper moins fort je vais te
dire derrière la porte tu vois alors
dis-moi alors vas-y toc toc toc déjà
[Rires]
[Musique]
le clown si tu n'existais pas
[Applaudissements]
le truc c'était clone si oui
tellement mal fait mais c'est sûr
[Applaudissements]
pour toi
aussi les peurs les bijoux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous allez me regretter
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
t'emmerde pas avec ça salut toi allez
c'est parti prochain toc toc c'est parti
tac tac tac
[Applaudissements]
la fée c'est la fête qui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fais-tu
c'est insupportable ce mec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
S
merci
[Applaudissements]
excusez-moi oui pourquoi tu es revenu
Pascal m'a appelé caca mou je croyais
que c'était pour moi
allez c'est parti prochain
coque qui est là c'est le chat noir
c'est noir
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a
[Musique]
tu as bien mangé ce weekend
tu as une toute petite balle de
ping-pong
[Applaudissements]
il faut que il faut que tu laisses comme
ça
je peux pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je ne te tape pas je ne te touche pas
regardez là ici on va là ici le genou
mais arrête pas le genou je montre le
genou il est cassé je ne te taperai pas
je fais du Shadow du Shadow du Shadow
regarde vas-y regarder là là là là
je me méfie
la violence déjà non non non
c'est vrai c'est vrai je dis une
connerie excusez-moi Christophe
[Rires]
elle est là
[Musique]
surtout les gaz le vrai truc qu'il faut
savoir c'est que elle a grillé totale la
meuf qui Cruella
Cruella
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu sais que sur ma vie
comme ça
peut être un délire c'est bon il est
très très lourd le manteau il fait 25
kilos pour l'instant pour moi c'est la
meilleure ce que je trouve qu'il y a eu
un truc il y a une elle a une
proposition artistique
Benjamin toi
pour elle voilà
[Applaudissements]
j'ai mal j'ai mal aux il faut que tu
travailles ça sinon tu n'arriveras pas
loin dans ton allez c'est parti toc qui
est là
ah tu l'as qui Dracula
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bien caler la musique une fois
non mais sans déconner les mecs ils
travaillent sur une autre émission ou
pas allez vas-y vas-y mon chéri
[Applaudissements]
il parle pas comme ça
[Musique]
il avait pas regardé la deuxième fois
non parce que ça y est c'est bon
franchement
sur deux minutes
comme ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'imagine les gens qui mettent la télé à
18h55
quelle est l'idée quel est le projet ça
va vous ça va très bien merci
[Applaudissements]
c'est beaucoup mieux comme ça
on dirait tiens un chanteur un peu de
pop anglaise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
calme-toi les mecs normalement ils sont
minimalisme dans leur vie
ils sont pas comme des ouf comme toi
c'est vrai c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
à toi tu donnes beaucoup pour pas
grand-chose
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas du tout
[Rires]
non même pas bon en tout cas bravo pour
l'interprétation
tu vas faire plaisir à Patrick Bruel
allez le dernier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est tombé elle est tombée
[Rires]
j'ai une chronique sur piano
électronique j'espère qu'on se marre
selon mes informations exclusives je
n'ai aucune information
il est beaucoup mieux comme ça avec la
coupe un peu comme ça
tu es en jus de citron en fait il faut
qu'on te creuse